you know Franciscan is one of the very
first schools that I ever spoke at after
I published my blank book and started my
uh for some reason it followed that I
had a public speaking career after the
blank book and this was one of the first
schools I I ever spoke at since that
time I've been to many college campuses
and every single time you know what
happens the libs call me all sorts of
names
they do me me lovable me can you imagine
can you imagine all the usual ones they
call me racist sexist
phobic
but the charge they hurl at me most
often these days
anti-science
they do I do doesn't matter what I'm
talking about could be talking about the
coronavirus gender global warming
whatever the most frequent accusation
these days tantamount to a charge of
blasphemy is that I am anti-science
and to that accusation I say
guilty is charged
I know that many conservatives fear
being called anti-science because it
makes them feel foolish and ignorant
that's why they try to ground all of
their arguments in scientific jargon
you know when the Liberals call us
anti-science for denying their alleged
breakthroughs in in the science of sex
and gender what do the conservatives do
we hurl it right back at them we accuse
them of being anti-science for denying
the scientific reality of sex
we refer to biological males biological
females
as if biology were the only thing that
mattered in the whole world
when the libs accuse us of being
anti-science for objecting to their
taking away all of our rights and
freedoms and way of life for two years
what do we do why we throw that insult
right back at them we say no you're
anti-science
and then we recite a Litany of
scientific Arguments for why hankies on
our face would not prevent a global
pandemic
as if there were no other reason other
than science
not to give all of our political power
away to a diminutive Technic rat in a
lab coat
when the Liberals call us anti-science
for doubting that the world will end in
10 years I think probably more like
eight or nine years now I forget when
AOC made the uh prophecy
when they when they when they call us
anti-science for doubting that if we
don't destroy our economy and radically
alter the way that we eat work get
around heat our homes do pretty much
everything else that we do what do we
say we say no
not uh you're anti-science and then we
cite our own statistics about sea levels
and storms and temperatures and whatever
as though science were the ultimate the
only Authority when it comes to
ascertaining the truth
I'm sick of it
I don't care if the Liberals call me
foolish or ignorant or a knuckled
dragging troglodyte
I don't I'm not going to play their game
I am not going to worship their false
god I am not going to take their
epistemological bait
it may be true okay that they call this
anti-science fine science is totally
fake there I said it
I don't care conservatives say we're not
anti-science maybe that's true but we
damn well should be as far as I'm
concerned we should at the very least be
much more skeptical of the pretenses of
science than we are right now
for starters
I don't know if you all are history
Buffs in this room but is it purely
historical matter science has been wrong
about pretty much everything at some
point for all of history
I'm not just talking about the past
couple of years I'm not just talking
about
the World Health Organization and the
CDC and the NIH and and our old pal Dr
fauci all of whom made mistakes and told
outright lies about kovid its origin The
Masks the social distancing the vaccines
the lockdowns and most everything else
I'm not even talking about relatively
recent historical scientific flubs say
at 1949 when the neurologist Antonio AGA
Moniz won the Nobel Prize for inventing
the lobotomy a little bit of a black
mark on science but I'm not even just
talking about that I mean to look much
more broadly at the category of science
as a whole because virtually every
single scientific theory about every
single thing has been disproved and
upended or replaced at some point
there was for example the theory of the
spontaneous generation of Life widely
accepted for Millennia that complex life
Springs from inanimate objects that was
knocked down in the 19th century by
Louis Pasteur who proved biogenesis the
notion that life is generated only from
other life the diversity of which it was
held for Millennia derives from a single
Act of Creation a theory that was
replaced according to scientists of the
17th century by a theory of
transmutation and then the genealogical
ascentive species which was in turn
replaced in the next Century by
Jean-Baptiste Lamarck's theory that
organisms pass on traits that they
acquired during their lives to their
children that was a theory that was in
turn disproven and replaced in the
following Century by Charles Darwin's
theory of natural selection and by
mendelian inheritance which in turn has
been complicated if not contradicted by
the observation of epigenetics and a
return to the former formerly
discredited views of Lamarck all of
which has been questioned in recent
years not only by Kooks and cranks but
by very serious scientists with very
Stellar academic credentials I'm
thinking of David berlinski from
Princeton David Galler from Yale who
have argued that the theory of evolution
is no longer mathematically tenable
I don't mention any of these theories of
life to endorse one over another but
simply to show that that science you
know she's a Fickle lady isn't she
she is and though the scientists are
frequently wrong they are almost never
in doubt
which is why today scientists and really
not even so much the scientists as the
broader Disciples of science insist that
we accept their current consensus on any
matter that they deem important
any topic global warming the origin of
life human sexuality You Name It We must
believe precisely The View that just so
happens to be fashionable in the year of
Our Lord 2022 or else we are ignorant
idiot science deniers
although wildly Divergent and
contradictory scientific theories have
constantly cropped up and collapsed
throughout all of human history today
apparently the scientists have resolved
every problem and know everything about
every other thing and that's never going
to change and only a dummy wouldn't
trust them
now some will object and say Michael
you're cherry picking
most other scientific theories are not
so Meandering and contradictory but
rather show a steady development and
progress say for example our
understanding of our own place in the
universe
contrary to a popular misconception we
have pretty much always known that the
Earth is not flat Pythagoras postulated
a spherical Earth about 500 years before
Christ but the ancient models placed the
Earth and therefore man at the center of
the universe in the second Century A.D
the astronomer Ptolemy observed that the
planets don't appear to orbit the earth
in perfect circles some planets in fact
like Mars seem to go backwards sometimes
before they go forward again this gave
rise to the theory of planetary
epicycles the idea that the planets go
around in circles as they more broadly
go around the Earth in circles this
theory was replaced in the 16th century
by Copernicus and the heliocentric model
which held that planets including the
Earth revolve around the sun though a
preface to his book the Revolutions of
the celestial spheres insisted that this
model was only for the purpose of
calculation and not to be taken
literally this is why Copernicus was
treated more nicely than say Mr Galileo
or some other people
later Tico brahey upended all of his
previous models by showing that the
celestial spheres do not exist which is
given way to various and Sundry theories
of the universe as finite and infinite
and static and expanding today the
predominant view is known as the Big
Bang which was observed by father George
lametra though present-day liberals who
are unsatisfied with the theory that
corresponds so well with the Christian
account of creation have theorized with
no evidence whatsoever that we're all
living in a Multiverse or a simulation
or a video game or I don't know whatever
in any case in any case
the present conception of the cosmos is
one in which Earth and Man exist as
infinitesimally small blips in some
far-flung part of cold dead space
but does that really represent the truth
of man's position
in a physical sense perhaps man is not
the center of the universe but in a
deeper sense man is in fact the center
of the universe man is where the
physical and the metaphysical Realms
meet that is not just some flight of
fancy it is not even solely the
understanding of Christians or some
other religious group it is in fact
uh just a simple fact accepted by all
people without which none of us could do
any of the things that we do every day
we all know and behave as though whether
we want to admit it or not man is both
body and rational Soul flesh and
intellect
animals exist in body but they don't
have a rational Soul this is why we
don't put cats on trial for scratching
people
ideas exist ideas motivate most much of
our Lives if not most of our lives but
ideas do not have bodies
dreams Joys Terrors these things exist
Angels demons these things exist too
even though some people don't want to
admit it
but none of those things have bodies
only in man do we see the meeting of
these two Realms that is the reason that
we and we alone in the world can even
talk about such things
so between the two conceptions of the
universe that we've just discussed the
ancient view of man at the center of the
cosmos and the modern scientific view of
man as an inconsequential blip in some
far-flung random region of emptiness
which is the more accurate
representation of reality which tells us
more about the way things really are
this is the point in the discussion when
one of my favorite words usually crops
up one of the most paradoxical words in
the English language
literally
people will be tempted to say well
Michael
it is literally true
that is they mean it might be
figuratively true that man is the center
of the universe but it is literally true
that the Earth revolves around the Sun
in the Milky Way galaxy in the Virgo
supercluster in the lania Kia
supercluster in the Pisces cetus
supercluster complex
which is located right in the middle of
God only knows where
but is that literally true
what does literally even mean
people tend to think of literal as
meaning the opposite of metaphorical or
symbolic
but that literally cannot be true
because literal refers to letters which
are symbols I am not being cute or
obtuse here well I'm always being cute
I'm always fine but I'm not I am not
being obtuse this is not just some trick
of language or some glib observation the
fact that even literal has a symbolic
meaning tells us something important
about the nature of reality
this is not a novel use of the word F
Scott Fitzgerald James Joyce Mark Twain
teenage girls since time immemorial have
all used literally to mean figuratively
it is not an error it's a crucial
insight
it is the Insight that nothing is
without meaning
modern Medical Science has led to many
Fine Things longer life better nutrition
better
Dentistry I don't know
it has also etched into our minds a new
representation of man as purely physical
at the very least fundamentally physical
a machine to be poked and prodded and
tuned up we reflect this in our language
we no longer get excited we just feel a
rush of adrenaline we no longer feel
happy we get a hit of dopamine we no
longer feel sad or blue or melancholic
now we have a chemical imbalance which
is a scientific representation by the
way that has just recently completely
Fallen apart even as a representation
but that's how we talk
modern astronomy has led to some
wonderful things
satellites for instance for smartphones
on which you can listen to the Michael
Knowles show phones on which you can go
to the bookstore and you can order my
books speechless controlling words
controlling Minds reasons to vote for
Democrats make superb Christmas presents
the wonderful things about astronomy
astronomy has also created a new
representation that makes man appear
random and insignificant and the
Scientific Revolution as a whole which
has helped to build our modern world has
placed in our Collective imagination a
representation of reality is
fundamentally physical
many of the greatest scientists in
history have been religious at least two
of the men that I just mentioned Mendel
and lemetra were Catholic priests and
Copernicus maybe was too he was at the
very least a Catholic Canon if not a
priest uh so I'm not casting aspersions
on scientists other than Dr fauci I am
casting many aspersions on Dr bouchi but
but on the other scientists I'm really
not
but our modern conception of reality is
fundamentally physical
is not the result of some nefarious
scientist it is a feature not a bug of
the whole Scientific Revolution which
necessarily considers the world only as
physical
the philosopher Owen Barfield predicted
all of this half a century ago in his
book saving the appearances Barfield saw
that the scientific worldview left
unchecked would eventually eliminate all
meaning and all coherence from the
cosmos he saw that it would lose its
grip on any principle of unity pervading
nature as a whole and the knowledge of
nature that it would give rise to the
hypothesis of chance Randomness creeping
from the theory of evolution into the
theory of the physical foundation of the
Earth itself and still worse cause an
increasing fragmentation of science
quote pigeonholed knowledge by
individuals of more and more about less
and less which if persisted indefinitely
can only lead mankind to a sort of
idiocy in which the breakdown of meaning
will mean that there will be no means of
communication between one intelligence
and another
does that sound familiar
sounds to me like Owen Barfield got in a
time machine and and described the year
2022 where the Sciences have become
absurd and words no longer seem to have
any meaning
we can no longer even agree on the
meaning of the word woman
a Supreme Court Justice
a woman
in her Senate confirmation hearings was
not able to Define
woman
why could she not Define him well
because she said she's not a biologist
this woman is a double Harvard grad this
woman is a federal judge put up for the
highest court in the land but she lacked
scientific credentials and therefore she
could not describe even her own identity
by the way
I sympathize with her I really do
we conservatives we all made fun of
Justice Jackson but frankly our answer
to that question has not been all that
much better than hers
our answer to that question what is a
woman has more or less been genitals and
chromosomes a woman is a person with a
womb and two X chromosomes that's what
we've said Justice Jackson's answer or
non-answer I guess is that woman means
more than just a womb and two X
chromosomes
in a way she was closer to the truth
than we conservatives have been
Justice Jackson like all the libs is
quite mistaken if she believes that some
hulking man in a mini skirt can actually
be a woman
but she is quite right to acknowledge
that women are more than their
chromosomes ironically when
conservatives Define women in that
purely physical way we accept the very
soul-denying scientism that the libs
have peddled to get us into this mess of
meaninglessness in the first place
when I was a kid I was taught
that girls are made of sugar and spice
and everything nice
today I am told that women are made of X
chromosomes whatever that is
which representation is closer to the
truth
of course it's not even close of course
sugar and spice and everything nice of
course
of course
that's much more clearly the reality of
what a woman is than X chromosomes does
man is the center of the universe
conveys much more clearly the reality of
our position than does
a rock around a ball of gas in the
Pisces cetus Super Galaxy cluster
the image and likeness of God conveys
much more precisely the reality of who
we are than does carbon and oxygen and
80 percent water
it is not the case as many people
mistakenly believe today that the
scientific view of things is objectively
true while the philosophical and
religious views are mere interesting
representations
they're all representations
all of it they're all just models
they're all just pictures
whatever image you have in your mind
right now of what the universe looks
like is only that it is only an image
even according to the most modern fancy
scientific models only five percent
of the universe is even visible
all the stars the planets the galaxies
every single thing that you imagine when
you imagine the universe
five percent according to the newest
models
twenty five percent of the universe so
five times the stuff that you are
thinking of is made up of dark matter
whatever that is a whopping seventy
percent so 14 times what you are
thinking of is the universe is made up
of dark energy
whatever that is
again it's all sort of a moot point
because whatever picture you have in
your mind of the visible Universe the
atoms and the protons and the photons
and all the other stuff you learned in
eighth grade
that is not really what the universe is
made of it's just a picture and I
promise you it is not a particularly
accurate picture at that
whatever we picture in our heads is
necessarily a representation scientific
religious anything in between that's not
a bad thing
representations are necessary for making
sense of the world for saving the
appearances to use Owen barfield's
phrase
but representations become Idols when we
mistake them for Ultimate Reality and
while we easily recognize Idols in the
context of religion the Scientific
Revolution with its attendant magic and
wonders has rendered us oblivious to the
ubiquitous idolatry of science
this is not only true of the libs this
is true of conservatives as well it is
not just the libs who wrap themselves in
the mantle of science but we
conservatives too who reach for
scientific observations
to prove all of our points
when conservatives object to
transgenderism
it is not usually on the basis of the
complementarity of the sexes
it's not usually on the basis of the
purpose and duties that go along with
sex
usually it's on the basis of science we
say so and so is a biological male so
and so is a biological female as though
one could could somehow simultaneously
be a biological male and a spiritual
female and a philosophical orangutan or
whatever whatever
and more to the point as though biology
that is the scientific representation
we're the ultimate Authority which it is
not
we more readily mistake the scientific
representations for Ultimate Reality
because we flatter ourselves with our
advancement in technology we have Teslas
and iPhones so we delude ourselves into
thinking that we have demystified the
Universe I can Doom scroll on that
little portal to hell that I keep in my
pocket so therefore you know I have
comprehended Ultimate Reality haven't I
I don't think so
that is nothing but flattery
yes we can tweet and drive and fly
but even our most sophisticated
scientific perspective leaves us unable
to answer fairly basic questions just
consider the three body problem I've
always loved the three body problem say
you've got three bodies you've got the
Sun the Moon and the Earth
say you know the initial position and
velocity of all three bodies it should
be very simple to know the subsequent
motion of those bodies right because
we're really smart and we have iPhones
and Teslas and we're so we're so
scientific right except we can't do it
and not only can we not know the
subsequent motion of those bodies but we
can know for a fact that we cannot know
it
it turns out that there is no General
closed form solution for their emotion
take Hilbert's problems if anyone has
taken a college math course you've
probably heard of Hilbert's problems 23
problems in mathematics put forward at
the turn of the 20th century by the
mathematician David Hilbert
122 years later not only do many of the
questions remain unresolved or only
partially resolved but in fact the first
two the Continuum hypothesis and the
consistency of the axioms of arithmetic
have been proven to be impossible to
prove
why do I mention this is it to discourse
on girdle and Cantor and all the other
mathematicians whose work I don't
understand at all no certainly is not
rather it is to point out the severe
limitations of human knowledge not just
what we don't know but what we provably
cannot possibly know
the scientific worldview more than other
representations has flattered us into
believing that we can comprehend and
therefore control Ultimate Reality it is
the pretense of the mad scientist in the
laboratory and the serpent in the Garden
of Eden the lie that we shall be as gods
in reality that appeal to our pride has
brought with its fun technological
trinkets overwhelming disenchantment and
confusion about who we are about what we
are for about what is a man about what
is a woman
the scientistic Liberals call us
ignorant
we are
we are ignorant though perhaps not quite
so ignorant as they if at least we know
it and can admit it they call us
anti-science
fine by me
it is good to see that the Earth
revolves around the Sun
it is better to see the love that moves
the sun and the other stars thank you
very much
[Applause]